so like many of you I watched the State
of the Union address last night this was
Donald Trump's first sort of official
State of the Union the one last year a
week or two into his presidency it
looked like a State of the Union and it
sounded like what a Donald Trump State
of the Union would be like but
traditionally not called the State of
the Union address when it's a new
president who's just taken over so
putative ly ostensibly the first real
Donald Trump State of the Union and I
watched in detail and I sat there
wrapped up in blankets to protect myself
from the horrible reality of what I was
seeing on TV and I plan to do like a
full analysis for you and do a
point-by-point breakdown talk about each
element of the speech and as I was
watching it and and thinking about it
afterwards in particular I realized that
you can't really do what I guess we
would call a normal analysis of the
speech so I'm not going to do that I'm
not gonna play a bunch of different
clips and react to them one by one I'm
just going to talk about it and give you
my sense of sort of what this speech
represents in the context of the first
year of the Trump presidency and the
outlook going forward when it comes to
the midterms and the possibility of
Donald Trump's maybe eventual reelection
and you sort of have the overall speech
to start with you have by the way what
was supposed to be an hour speech but
because of the applause as well as just
the insanely slow nature of Donald
Trump's delivery it ended up being like
an hour and a half then you say Pat an
hour twenty something like that the
applause has to be banned I think the
press is very problematic now didn't you
watch it the the entire thing at 2x
speed oh yeah for the fact was brilliant
yeah I was smart enough to watch it
later on yeah once it was on YouTube and
then you can change the speed so like
1.5 X 2 X I watched it twice the speed I
should have done that and then I could
have watched it in half the time so
you've got this entire speech right an
hour and 20 something minutes speech or
however long it was to really analyze
the meat of the speech you have to first
take away all of the planned emotional
moments where the president tells an
inspiring or emotional story about a
guest in the crowd a soldier a police
officer the adopter of a bay
be born addicted to opioids all
presidents do that it's a show it's not
really what you analyze but it
influences people's perception of how
the speech went and Trump happened to do
a lot of that Trump even opened with
some of those I want to say hi to this
and that person normally the president's
thick that stuff in certainly in the
second half of the speech usually around
like the two-thirds or three-quarters of
the way through mark Trump almost opened
with some of that stuff yeah there was
that North Korea defector the gabbie was
giving out flags to put on the grave
sites of a lot of these individuals and
that's not really anything to analyze
right so we scratched those parts from
her from our analysis then we can do an
analysis of the accomplishment that the
president claims for themselves from the
prior year and compare it to the sort of
reality of what took place Donald Trump
did a lot of bragging a lot of the
bragging was about things that weren't
real the other half was about things
that I wouldn't be bragging about one
example of this is Trump bragged about
his attempt to resuscitate what he
called beautiful clean coal which isn't
a thing it's a polluting fossil fuel
that's just one example of what Trump
bragged about that's not really
something to brag about so then once you
say okay fine so they've done the
emotional stuff and they've gotten us to
feel connected to this person in the
crowd or that person in the crowd and
they sort of seem like a normal person
and by the way I don't want to go
completely off the rails but did anybody
else notice most presidents when they
point to someone in the upper deck a
special guest and there's an emotional
tribute the president looks at them
while he is clapping but Trump is so
narcissistic and it's all about self
aggrandizement that when he would do
those emotional moments he would clap
but be looking around and over his
shoulder to see how other people were
reacting to his emotional tribute like
every aspect of this thing was totally
depraved but okay we get past the
padding on the back we get past the
emotional moments and we get to policy
analysis well that's a problem because
Donald Trump may
a lot of statements that sort of sounded
like they were about policy but other
than saying he's going to keep
Guantanamo Bay detention center open in
Cuba an outlining sort of a plan on
immigration although it wasn't really a
plan but it kind of was an idea of what
could maybe be a plan there was very
little in this nearly 90-minute speech
in terms of policy to even analyze there
were really no proposals or ideas on the
environment which Trump doesn't really
think is a problem taxes Trump believes
that taxes is done
he believes that taxes has been solved
nothing on health care other than again
cheerleading the repeal of the
individual mandate which in and of
itself is not really a solution to
anything he cheered what he's doing
partially inaccurately but there were no
real policy proposals to speak of it you
know he dangled this thing and you
mentioned this to me Pat this way of
safeguarding the 1.8 million
undocumented people that came to the US
as kids it relates to daca but in
outlining that plan he made it very
clear that many of the current
provisions around immigration need to be
scrapped and that's gonna be terrible
for a lot of people usually the
president offers some new policy
proposals he just rehashed the things
he's been saying yeah to offer some
silver linings though which is a Miss
for yes yes he had that 1.5 trillion
dollar infrastructure proposal now a lot
of it is corporate handout of course a
firmly capitalist state and local
governments yeah paid family leave was
another one and then an emphasis on
trying to lower the cost of prescription
drugs yeah no I don't know how he's
going to do that but that's the planning
you know Trump campaigned on lowering
the cost of prescription drugs and then
shortly after being elected he had a
meeting with Pharma insurance lobbyists
and he came out and all of a sudden it
wasn't important anymore to lower the
price of prescription drugs so now he's
put that back I guess on the list again
with no plan as to how he would really
do it so it's not really a policy
proposed arrad Kushner's responsibility
once he solves peace in the Middle East
he'll get that he'll move on to that
next the one specific policy or
actionable idea that Trump mentioned
that actually I do want to discuss is
really scary in a sort of authoritarian
way Donald Trump said quote tonight I
all on the Congress to empower every
every cabinet secretary with the
authority to reward good workers and to
remove federal employees who undermine
the public trust or fail the American
people this slipped by a lot of people
yesterday and the implications of it are
incredibly dangerous what Donald Trump
is effectively calling for here is
completely anti-democratic what Trump
suggested is that any cabinet member of
trumps could decide unilaterally there
are people under my supervision that are
they've they've destroyed public trust
in them they've undermined the public
trust and I am going to fire these
people that could be someone who as part
of their role at the FBI is conducting
an investigation imagine that that
investigation was hypothetically oh I
don't know into possible Trump collusion
with Russia during the election or
cover-up of that collusion and a cabinet
member could unilaterally decide Jeff
Sessions for example who runs the
Justice Department the as Attorney
General could say they've undermined the
trust of the public and I am going to
fire that person on the spot and what
this goes to is eliminating the supposed
Independence of agencies like the FBI
and the Department of Justice and others
it's a very dangerous disaster and it's
mostly flown under the radar because of
the language Trump used right I mean I
got to be honest this flew under my
radar too maybe it was because I was
watching it at two times the speed but I
think it was more because it was just so
vaguely worded and it just sounds like
more oversight and rule of law rhetoric
to me it sounds like empowering people
to reward good employees and to get rid
of bad employees but it's a framework
that could justify the firing of Robert
Moeller for example it can create a
pretext for all sorts of authoritarian
manipulation by Trump it is very very
dangerous and that to me was a really
scary moment of the speech and then
lastly if we want to think about a State
of the Union address as an attempt to do
bipartisan diplomacy as a way to extend
an olive branch to
the other side the right has cheered
Trump for extending an olive branch in
this speech they talked about how many
times Trump used the word we' and talked
about Democrats and Republicans working
together but just because you talk about
working together doesn't your speech is
action doesn't mean your speech is
actually going to have the effect of
being a uniting force and in fact the
rhetoric of Trump speech was very
divisive not uniting it was in short
let's work together and compromise for
the good of the American people and the
betterment of America as long as you
agree to what Trump wants to do
effectively . yeah when he was talking
about immigration policy he cut to the
parents of two teenage girls who were
killed by ms-13 members that's right now
you can mention some of the more
positive tales of immigration some
success story I mean Trump's own wife
and mother were immigrants as well we
got to that instead he cut to that and
by the way I haven't fact checked this
but he talked about thousands and
thousands of ms-13 members in the United
States who have been deported I don't I
just remembered I didn't fact check that
it's salad we've deported thousands and
thousands of members of that one
particular gang plus ms-13 started in LA
- yeah right that's a complete other
thing which is a lot of the people in
ms-13 from the beginning yes they were
from immigrant families at some point
and maybe personally but not necessarily
here illegally those were weird numbers
I didn't look them up but I'd be curious
what the truth is but yeah Trump talked
about bringing the nation together
despite being the reason that it's being
torn apart and he talked about respect
and the rule of law when he was trying
to interfere in the separation of powers
and judicial independence he's done it
trying to meddle in the Russia
investigation he's doing it by
suggesting as I just mentioned minutes
ago that any cabinet secretary could
just fire whoever they want if they have
undermined the public trust it was
effectively a gong show and when you get
to the end and you strip out the
carefully concocted inspirational
stories about people in the audience the
applause lines the vague meaningless
comments about unity and partnership you
are left with a president who spent an
hour and a half
bragging about things that are either
imaginary or terrible
proposing no real policy to speak of and
extending no actual olive branches for
bipartisanship period it was a joke of a
speech and exactly as I predicted
yesterday his base absolutely loved it
the base is influenced by this garbage
when the base sees Trump praised the
parents of otto warmbier who died
shortly after getting back from North
Korea completely tragic that makes them
approve of the speech even though any
president can invite them and say hi to
them and say this is a tragic thing it
tells us nothing about policy when Trump
says let's work together and get past
our differences the Trump is base says
oh good speech even though that doesn't
actually portray or or transmit any
meaning or value when the policies are
incompetent at best and actively
divisive at worst the best analysis I
heard Beth analogy was Van Jones on CNN
and everybody knows I've had a falling
out with Van Jones which I wish we could
fix it happened a couple years ago he
said that this is basically sweet
tasting candy with poison in it is what
Donald Trump's speech was it was a
rhetoric that sort of sounded like what
some people want to hear but the
underpinnings of it are actually
completely toxic well last year he was
the guy who said that you know this is
the night that Trump becomes president
that's right when he gave that first
address to Congress you know I guess
he's got to step up the rhetoric in
support of the progressive side in this
instance I actually think we could say
listen Van Jones said what he genuinely
felt last time and he's saying what he
genuinely feels this time and what he
feels mirrors what I feel what I feel
not what I feels not my feel what I'm
saying will Trump get an approval bump
from this I don't know we'll see in a
couple days send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman we are on Twitter as
a show at david pakman show and I'm
curious to see what people in the
audience thought the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership